here's a question what's done really
well online for the Scottish National
Party this year you won't get it so I'll
tell you it's this gift of Nicola
Sturgeon since it was uploaded in
February it's had more than 1.4 million
views
more than 30,000 times the SNP is most
popular video on YouTube the SMP also
makes stickers like this one which can
be added to an image and apps like
Instagram this one's had over two
hundred and eight thousand views and in
total the SMPS gifts and stickers have
had nineteen point nine million views in
the last three years now that's partly
because these clips are so short but
it's also because they're accessible and
apps like whatsapp and Facebook
Messenger the private chat apps where
people are increasingly spending their
time and that's why labour and the
Conservatives have followed the SNP and
started making their own gifts and
stickers the Lib Dems haven't caught on
yet this is the most popular labour
sticker and this is the most popular
conservative one and the reason this is
so effective is because this content
goes onto the system used by the mobile
phone keyboard where people will simply
dial it up without ever suspecting it
was made by a party when we're trying to
sell fashion products to pharmaceuticals
to finance it's all about being relevant
and relatable being personal and not
stuck on a pedestal and looking down
Allan tumours it's relating to them and
becoming part of their culture now of
course the question is who's winning the
gift game this graph shows all the
searches made during the campaign on
giffy the gift section which powers that
give button in our keyboards and this
spike here is the day of the first
leaders debate on this day Boris Johnson
ranks between 180 and 250 in the UK for
all gift search terms and gif he told us
that given that we have so many
evergreen popular search items like love
hello that ranking is already very
impressive
of course there is a huge caveat we
don't know what gives people were
sharing about Boris Johnson they might
have been sent ironically or even
insulting Lee it does happen but in a
way that's the key point
we just don't know more and more
political activity is taking place in
this kind of app and that might be a
good thing for privacy but it means of
viral ideas are going to pop up
unexpectedly we've seen India and Brazil
how those ideas can change the course of
elections gifts give us a glimpse into
this hidden world but for the most part
we're navigating blind